um so
i guess uh what i i don't have any
disagreement with that uh
at least right now um i i i'm in
agreement with this idea
uh that when we're talking about
uh perception and
we're talking about doing things in
terms of a context dependence
and then the sensitivity to that the
sensitivity to context and con concept
context dependence i think is really
really crucial i see that sensitivity as
bound up with
the capacity for interpretation
interpretation means
being able to
in some way direct your attention or
your awareness to some features rather
than others because you can of course
take in all possible features of of the
object or the environment etc
so i guess i see those two processes as
a little bit more closely related and
i do think that part of what it's like
to experience a face
is to find it relevant in a particular
fashion to find it as fitted to that
context and fitted to your task within
that context
and i think that
also as joshua said i think that goes
into the perception of it so i see i
guess perhaps a deeper interpenetration
between
the perception and the interpretation
this goes around ideas like i've been
talking about about relevance
realization
um
now
there's there was an interesting um move
made there and i don't know how fast we
want to go onto logical um where there
was um
you know the face isn't really there
and
um
it's just a projection um
and so um i'm not quite sure what that
means uh maybe yoshi can
uh because i take it for example
um that
that would generalize to everything in
my experience um that i find meaningful
um and
like
do i want to say
that the various you know gauges i'm
using in science are just projections um
do i want to say that the other people
that are debating with me are just
projections so i get something to do
yeah
uh but the problem is is is
um there's an implicit normativity of
realness there
that
um i guess i want i uh i want to unpack
a little bit uh because like i said i
think the point that yoshime just
generalizes to everything
and then i
i have sort of epistemological and
ontological concerns about that
because it might i'm not saying it does
i'm saying it might sort of lead me into
kind of a solar cystic skepticism which
makes the very pro the very attempt to
do science itself kind of implausible um
so
what is it i mean surely there might
surely maybe not surely
there must be
a perception that counts as observation
of the environment i take it
and
why is it not just a projection i guess
is my question
yes so
this particular point uh relates to the
question of whether faces are part of
res extensor
and
we have to uh sort out what we mean by
res extensor the typical way in which
descartes is interpreted is that there
are two substances out in physics in a
way ontologically at the level at which
the universe exists and one of these
substances is stuff in space
the extended things the objects in the
world and then we have res cognitives
which is the space of ideas in which the
mind exists and somehow they interact
with each other so basically the mind
exists in a different dimension of the
universe and remote controls the
physical body
via the pineal gland or
as popper and eckel suggested via the
neocortex which is some kind of magical
quantum antenna which talks to the mind
in a different realm that is not in
physics and i think this is an um
misunderstanding that
ultimately can be mapped to faulty on
epistemology so there is a
weird perspective on what we think is
and in the way in which it is
constituted it's also reflected in the
christian interpretation of the genesis
and maybe this is not unrelated because
it's part of the same cultural tradition
this interpretation of genesis and the
interpretation of descartes
and
in genesis we have the creation of a
physical universe by a supernatural
being in in the common interpretation
and it starts out with the creation of
light and darkness which are separated
from each other and then the creation of
sky and ground and then the plants and
the animals eventually and then they all
get their name
but we do know that uh sky and ground
are not physical entities
and colors are not in physics there are
constructions that only happen in our
mind and and when we look at
foundational physics we see a weird
quantum graph that has
a very complicated properties among them
apparently the property to throws
regular patterns at our systemic
interface so our brain can find
regularity in them and part of these
regularities that our mind is
discovering in quite reliable ways is uh
darkness and brightness and sky and
ground and plants and animals and giving
them all their names which is cognitive
development so the universe that you and
me are interacting with
experientially and also
intersubjectively is not a physical
universe we are not talking about
entities in physics when we talk uh
about the universe to each other we
largely talk about entities in our
experience
and now it turns out that this
experience that our brain is
constructing for us to relate to which
is a core screening of the patterns that
the physical universe throws at us
contain
two types of entities
and one group of entities is what we
could call stuff in space it's like a
physics engine in a computer game so we
have
a three-dimensional basically euclidean
space in which we have extended objects
that occupy volumes and these objects
can be solid or liquid or gaseous and
they uh displace each other and they
have all these properties that we would
call res extensor but this res extensor
is geometric it's mechanical
it doesn't want something it's just
moving in a mechanical way
and so when the student said that there
are no faces
in power sockets what she meant is that
the physical thing the res extends i
think the geometrical thing the face
is not really on the power plug and i
pointed to her out that the face itself
is not a geometrical thing so when you
see a face what you see is not actually
a geometry it's not part of something
that you would construct with a 3d
program
what you have to construct is a certain
part of rescogins it's a certain
interpretation of a high level feature
that is already a mental feature that we
see this intentional entity in the world
expressed by uh its interface to the
world
and so i think this way we can uh john
and me probably agree on
a way in which we disassemble the
category or at least make the next step
and so i would agree that of course
every entity that we make out in the
universe ultimately is an imposition
that our mind is making this imposition
is not necessarily an arbitrary one
because the universe cannot be
officially encoded in every possible way
there are certain ways in which the
encoding makes sense and others where it
doesn't help you to interpret the world
so the way in which we
draw the boundaries between objects is
not arbitrary but the boundaries are
drawn by our mind